madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
que nous allons développer dans ce
journal la fin du sommet de l'otan
washington la réunion des sept pays
voisins de la yougoslavie avec les
membres de l'alliance pour un pacte de
stabilité dans les balkans
jacques chirac qui avait initié cette
rencontre vient de tenir une conférence
de presse dans un message a fort mal aux
français il revient sur la situation au
kosovo
réaffirmant l'unité de l'otan contre
slobodan milosevic le df ce n'est
aujourd'hui son conseil national
l'ardeur de françois bayrou qui entre
dans la campagne pour une liste autonome
sur le thème de l'europe dans la clarté
cinéma avec la sortie mercredi prochain
du plus beau pays du monde réalisé par
marcel bluwal l'histoire vraie sous
l'occupation de cet acteur qui incarne
le rôle de mermoz pour un film
propagande avant d'être déportés j'ai le
plaisir de recevoir que le brasseur
c'est donc à l'initiative de la france
que les représentants des sept pays
voisins de la yougoslavie
particulièrement fragilisées par la
situation au kosovo ont participé à une
réunion de l'otan cet après-midi à
washington
clôturant ainsi ce sommet anniversaire
de l'alliance au cours duquel les alliés
viennent d'adopter un pacte de stabilité
pour les balkans philippe gassot
pendant toute la durée du sommet il a
été question de guerre ce matin on a
parlé de faits à la demande du président
français
les représentants de l'albanie post ni
bulgarie croatie macédoine roumanie et
slovénie était réunie s'agissait de
rassurer les pays riverains du conflit
et les assurer du soutien et de l'aide
des pays de l'otan
la communauté européenne sera sollicité
ainsi que les organismes internationaux
tels que le fmi ou la banque mondiale
il s'agissait ce matin d'adresser au
pays risquant d'être déstabilisé par le
conflit un message de solidarité tout en
indiquant à slobodan milosevic des
limites à ne pas franchir
l'otan a pris une position très claire
nous avons 10 sans ambiguïté si belle
graves changements à ses voisins en
raison de la présence de l'otan nous
répondrons suspendre les efforts et les
difficultés rencontrées par les
riverains ont été soulignés lula était
bien entendu question du sort des
réfugiés et des risques encourus par les
pays d'accueil la réunion d'aujourd'hui
aura sans doute donné au pays de la
ligne de front
empêtré dans des problèmes jusqu'ici
insurmontable des raisons d'espérer et
aussi de patienter il y un peu plus
d'une demi-heure jacques chirac à
washington tenait une conférence de
presse auparavant le président de la
république dans un message informel ou
français a rappelé la détermination de
l'alliance réaffirmant l'unité de l'otan
contre slobodan milosevic
je vous propose tout de suite d'écoutés
le chef de l'état de washington qu'il
devait à l'origine célébrer le 50e
anniversaire de l'alliance atlantique a
été réalité le sommet de l'unité 2
dix-neuf pays de l'alliance réunit dans
un même combat pour la démocratie et
pour les droits de l'homme les états de
l'alliance ont été unanimes à condamner
le comportement abominable des
dirigeants de belgrade qui poursuivent
sauvagement la politique d'épuration
assistent leurs massacres leur violence
bio et beach n'a pas changé son
entêtement meurtrier demeure entier et
le nombre de ces victimes ne cesse
d'augmenter
devant cette situation nos démocraties
on d'une même voix décidé de confirmer
leur stratégie de frappes aériennes
comme la france l'avait souhaité de les
amplifier et de diversifier les
objectifs afin de paralyser le plus vite
possible l'appareil de répression serbe
de même les mesures d'embargo sur les
armes et le pétrole nécessaire aux
forces serbes ont été décidées par
l'union européenne puis par l'alliance
la france a souligné l'importance du
respect du droit international dans la
conduite de cette action nous avons
aussi décidé de renforcer les moyens mis
en oeuvre par l'alliance pour faire face
à la tragédie qui frappe des centaines
de milliers de réfugiés
des enfants des femmes des hommes
brutalement chassée de chez eux s'est
pas fait ayant tout perdu
ce tragédie a bouleversé l'ensemble de
nos peuples
l'élan de générosité s'amplifie les
associations humanitaires sont de plus
en plus présente et s'organisent
la france demande que l'appui de nos
armées respecte l'indépendance de ces
associations qui souhaitent cette aide
mais qui veulent conserver cette
indépendance qui leur est nécessaire
nous avons aussi affirmé la volonté
notre volonté de se courir ceux qui sont
restés au kosovo dans une situation de
plus en plus dramatique
malgré les difficultés techniques qui
sont réelles la france a demandé que
tout soit mis en oeuvre pour leur venir
en aide notamment par des parachutage de
vivres et de médicaments
mais la crise a aussi de graves effets
sur l'ensemble de la région et notamment
sur l'albanie et sur la macédoine
la france avait demandé qu'un sommet
réunissent les alliés et les sept pays
voisins de la serbie pour examiner avec
l'aide que l'otan doit leur apporter
pour assurer leur sécurité
ce sommet vient d'avoir lieu valiant se
tient aux côtés de ces états nous sommes
décidés à préserver leur stabilité
la situation du monténégro a été
particulièrement examiné et la serbie
doit savoir qu'elle subirait toutes les
conséquences d'un coup de force dans
cette petite république
mais au delà de l'indispensable
renforcement de nos actions militaires
au delà de la solidarité que nous devons
à ceux qui souffrent il y à la
nécessaire recherche d'une solution
politique
des efforts des alliés doivent se
conjuguer avec ceux de l'onu et aussi
avec ceux de la russie qui vous le savez
tente de convaincre belgrade de revenir
à la raison
enfin la france a réaffirmé la vocation
et la volonté de l'europe a joué un rôle
déterminant dans la mise en oeuvre le
moment venu d'une solution durable à
washington j'ai pu mesurer combien la
voix de la france deuxième puissance par
les moyens militaires engagés étaient
renforcées par l'unité évidente du
peuple français
cette unité dont il fait preuve depuis
le début du conflit la détermination et
la mobilisation de la france pour la
défense des droits de l'homme pour la
défense des libertés donne un autre pays
une place éminente en europe et dans le
monde
cette unité du peuple français
impressionne et je tiens ce soir à la
saluer et en direct de washington nous
rejoignant laurent boussier on notera
dans le message de jacques chirac la
fermeté de ton du président de la
république à l'encontre de slobodan
milosevic
oui absolument béatrice détermination et
fermeté et c'est normal puisque le
message délivré ici par les dix-neuf
chefs d'état de l'alliance atlantique en
direction de slobodan milosevic
ce message est un message d'unité et de
fermeté alors vous l'avez entendu le
président de la république a tiré une
sorte de bilan de ces trois jours ici
avec les deux points qui considèrent
comme les plus importants le premier set
évidemment le kosovo pour l'instant on
ne change pas de stratégie
on garde la même on amplifie les frappes
et surtout on ne se donne pas de
limitation de durée
on évoque aussi un embargo pétrolier
sans savoir vraiment comment on va
pouvoir le mettre en oeuvre
et puis surtout on ne parle surtout pas
d intervention terrestre que personne ne
veut parce que personne ne veut mourir
pour le kosovo deuxième point très
important abordé par le président les
pays riverains c'est à dire les pays qui
sont autour de la yougoslavie on les
aime
on l'est on veut les aider mais on ne
veut pas les intégrer alors on leur
propose une sorte de pacte de stabilité
on préfère prévenir que guérir il n'en
reste pas moins que de ce sommet en
observateur un peu extérieur
on ressent un certain malaise comme si
ici les chefs d'état qui ont participé à
participer à ce sommet avait mieux
réussi à parler du futur des problèmes
futurs qu'à régler les problèmes du
moment c'est à dire les problèmes du
présent
merci laurent boussier en fin de matinée
le commandant en chef de l'otan est
arrivé en albanie le général wesley
clark a entamé une tournée d'inspection
notamment des troupes américaines
basé près de tirana là où sont déployés
les hélicoptères apache
cet après midi la télévision serbe une
nouvelle fois prise pour cible la nuit
dernière a recommencé à émettre après
plusieurs heures de silence pour cette
33e journée de bombardements nouvelle
alerte à belgrade alors qu'aux
frontières continue d'affluer les
réfugiés chassés du kosovo le hcr parle
aujourd'hui d'un massacre de 56
personnes selon des témoignages et
récits qui n'ont pas encore été
recoupées olivier galzi 32e
de bombardements
cible visée par les avions de l'otan le
centre industriel de niche une usine
chimique à cap chat qui est surtout
l'alimentation électrique de la
télévision serbe sur le moins vallat
voici la reprise des programmes sur la
rts cet après midi l'image est de
mauvaise qualité
mais 11 heures après la frappe la
télévision diffuse à nouveau
d'abord un clip à la gloire de l'armée
serbe
et puis lors du bulletin d'information
des images présentées comme étant le
résultat du bombardement sur le centre
d'alimentation électrique de la rts hier
des images guerre de l'information c'est
la deuxième fois que la chaîne d'état il
disait une chaîne qualifié d' outil de
propagande par l'otan ceci est l'un des
derniers reportages diffusés hier par la
télévision serbe
on y voit le général nadarevic
commandant du corps de kristina avec
c'est trop
la scène se passerait dans une zone
frontalière avec l'allemagne et ses
hommes dit le commentaire son prêt taf
c'est une offensive terrestre
et pendant ce temps là justement dans le
sud de la macédoine des hélicoptères
italien de type mangouste s'entraînait à
la lutte anti chars prévus aussi pour la
destruction des tanks mais deux fois
plus puissant que leur équivalent
italien sept nouveaux apache américains
sont arrivés cet après-midi à tirana
côté réfugiés plus de 1500 kosovars sont
entrés aujourd'hui en macédoine par le
poste frontière de blatche et et
toujours ces mêmes images d'exode
famille au désespoir mais les histoires
seraient cette fois particulièrement
atroces on ne peut pas confirmer ces
témoignages mais plusieurs personnes
nous ont relaté des histoires de mafia
vingt-et-une personnes auraient été
tuées dans un village
certaines d'entre elles auraient même
été violés et aurélie est toujours selon
le hcr d'autres témoignages parlerait de
56 personnes massacrées dans des
villages au sud de pristina des unités
paramilitaires serbes auraient même
arraché les yeux de certains cadavres
autre lieu autre histoire ici à morina
les soldats serbes ont rappelé les
réfugiés qui voulait partir
c'est la première fois que cela arrive
ils leur ont demandé de rentrer chez eux
difficile de savoir exactement ce qu'il
se passe de l'autre côté de la frontière
la slovénie a autorisé le temps à
utiliser son espace aérien et la
macédoine a accepté en fin d'après-midi
d'accueillir sur son territoire des
troupes britanniques et allemandes
supplémentaires soit 4 me nomme et puis
il ya quelques instants
c'est là où gré à son tour qui autorise
l'alliance à utiliser ces bases
aériennes pour des raids contre la
yougoslavie partant à présent en
macédoine où les serbes de skopje au
moment où s'ouvrait le sommet de
l'alliance vendredi dernier ont
symboliquement procédé aux obsèques de
l'otan sous les applaudissements de la
foule
diverses manifestations contre les
frappes aériennes dans ce pays
multiethnique où l'on compte aujourd'hui
une communauté serbe de quarante mille
membres
reportage dans la banlieue de tetovo
richard binet patrick dissimulé
le hurlement des sirènes
puis le grondement des bombes comme si
la guerre allait brusquement fait
irruption à brûler nitza un village à
l'ouest de skopje
la manifestation est orchestrée par le
dps le parti serbe de macédoine avec un
goût prononcé pour la mise en scène
je crache sur ta tombe de clinton
je crache sur ta femme et tes enfants
mort à l'amérique
nous ne lâcherons pas le kosovo n'a eu
que cela dit vivre à c'est tout
l'occident qui est en accusation et
notre caméra n'est pas forcément la
bienvenue
les orateurs serbes se sont succédé à la
tribune
le public est remonté draghi chat
miletitch le leader serbe de macédoine
peut faire son entrée
les serbes savent qu'ils peuvent compter
sur leurs frères macédoniens et que vous
êtes avec nous pour sauver la
yougoslavie dans la foule des
macédoniens inquiet de voir la guerre
s'approchaient de leur frontière mais au
delà des slogans contre l'otan ce sont
bien les albanais qui sont visés nous
sommes ici pour lutter contre les
fascistes que sont les clinton chirac
solana tous vous êtes serbe
non je suis macédonien y tue les petits
enfants il tue vos collègues des
journalistes et eu aussi les cernes vous
êtes serbe
je suis un esquimau parce qu'il ya
tellement de pingouins ici des lgv année
je n'ai que je me sens comme un esquimau
les serbes de macédoine ne représente
que 3% de la population
mais depuis l'afflux de réfugiés 137000
à ce jour le leader serbe rassemble
derrière lui non seulement les
nationalistes macédonien mais aussi de
simples citoyens effrayés par cet afflux
massif d'albanais et qui craignent qu'un
jour leur pays ne se transforme en un
nouveau kosovo en albanie maintenant
tout près de la frontière avec le kosovo
dans cette zone à risque où le hcr
commence d'évacuer vers le sud pour plus
de sécurité les réfugiés les sauveteurs
de la sécurité civile française ont
décidé eux d'implanter une nouvelle
structure dans cette région claude
samper bernie mériaux l'extrême nord de
l'albanie près de la frontière avec le
kosovo
sur la route nous rencontrons ce convoi
de sept tracteurs avec 81 réfugier sur
le dernier se trouve la famille de
madame masri coup au volant son fils de
14 ans que dans la remorque
ses deux belles filles et leurs enfants
madame maastricht où nous raconte sa
fuite du village des menaces des
policiers serbes armée de biselx
automatique les coûts les vols de bijoux
d'argent et sont arrivés ici en albanie
toute la famille mazeray coup se dirige
vers un nouveau camp qui vient d'être
montée par la sécurité civile française
un camp qui vient d'ouvrir et qui est
installée à quelques kilomètres de la
frontière les accompagner jusqu'à une
tente dans laquelle seront enregistrées
on va prendre leurs noms et les âges de
toute cette zone est pourtant considéré
par le haut commissariat aux réfugiés
comme une zone de guerre
apportez tirs des canons sert
actuellement dans la zone on est en
train d'évacuer les réfugiés du secteur
de couriège parce qu'on considère que
c'est devenu charisme et vous vous avez
installé un camp en pleine mue
sur ces points là je pars je peux rien
dire
quel va être l'avenir de ce camp
l'avenir pour nous l'installer pour
qu'il soit jusqu'à la fin de l'été
jusqu'en septembre octobre
maintenant nous on va finir
l'installation va rester encore à peu
près une petite semaine et on va passer
le relais
j'ai sur place pendant que madame
mavericks où s'installe et découvre sa
nouvelle habitation
nous essayons de comprendre pourquoi ce
camp était installée ici alors que le
hcr a décidé d'emmener les réfugiés plus
au sud en sécurité si on est bien vous
savez c'est très très bien je vous
remercie beaucoup
les autorités françaises et albanaises
ont décidé de monter le camp ici car ils
craignent un nouvel afflux de réfugiés
ensuite on va leur donner notre camp se
justifie jeudi à la détresse est partout
donc je veux dire il n'est pas inutile
actuellement les villages sont saturés
j'estime que le camp c'est le joker je
veux dire le joker pour le réfugié pas
inquiet pour l'avenir de ce camp
aucunement aucunement pas d'inquiétude
pour l'avenir pourtant il ne reste ici
que cinq jours de vivre et à ce jour
aucune ong ne s'est proposé pour
reprendre la gestion du corps
loin de tous ces débats hcr autorités
françaises autorités albanaises
en cette fin d'après midi la famille de
manama vrai coup était très heureuse de
retrouver un peu de paix le calme des
nouveaux vêtements et de nouvelles
chaussures
dans la capitale historique du
monténégro à c'est signé se rassemblent
ces jeunes patriotes qui refuse à tout
prix leurs feuilles de mobilisation dans
l'armée yougoslave et on ce dimanche ce
jour des offices religieux
une véritable dissidence face au pouvoir
de slobodan milosevic a pris corps dans
l'une des églises orthodoxes ont monté
les grès une reportage benoît duquesne
jean françois renaud
ce devrait être un havre de paix une
parenthèse dans cette guerre une matinée
de prière dans une église orthodoxe
nous sommes au monastère de c'est signé
berceau de l'église monténégrin pourtant
la tranquillité n'est qu'apparente car
le métropolite qui officie maintenant a
été nommé par belgrade
c'est un proche de milosevic un temps
réputé pour avoir abrité arcanes laisser
sinistre milice
alors pour ceux qui viennent ici église
serbe et monténégrine ne doivent pas
recule
comme de rester unis la fédération
yougoslave
pour nous les patriotes comme pour la
majorité du peuple que ce soit mais le
grade ou s'est il y est c'est la même
chose c'est la même entité
quant au kosovo nous pensons tous que
c'est le fondement spirituel de notre
patrie et on ne permettra en aucun cas
être séparés mais dans cette ville de
15000 habitants cette ancienne capitale
du royaume monténégrins avec ses palais
ses ancienne ambassade
ce discours est devenu minoritaire ici
on a voté largement pour l'actuel
président monténégrins qui a pris ses
distances avec belgrade
on y rêve même d'indépendance de
grandeur retrouvée et pourquoi pas d'une
église qui ne seraient plus rattachées à
la capitale serbe
c'est ici il ya sept ans tenait le
comité du renouveau pour l'église
monténégrin un mouvement qualifié de
politique par le patriarcat de belgrade
mais un commencement d'église
indépendante un commencement
d'opposition aussi le rôle d'occupation
monte la seule église officielle c'est
l'église monténégrin
elle n'a jamais cessé d'exister dans la
conscience des ridelles on existera
toujours
sacha pas jovic fait partie de ses
fidèles
mais comme beaucoup ici son opposition à
belgrade va encore plus loin jusque dans
le refus d'obéir aux ordres de
mobilisation de l'armée serbe
alors les jeunes se sont organisés et
regroupés armés et leurs seuls cohésion
pour l'instant leur a permis de tenir
l'armée venus ici pour m'emmener de
force mais mes amis étaient là une
trentaine ils leur ont expliqué qu'on ne
voulait pas intégrer leurs armes et que
c'était des soldats d'occupation et
qu'il se battrait que pour défendre le
monténégro mais sacha paillot vilchez du
site il s'est exhibé des ordres de
mobilisation qu'on ne respectera pas ou
bien carburer l'ancien drapeau du
royaume montée des grains ne sont que
des victoires passagère face à une armée
serbe qui a d'autres arguments en
grande-bretagne et aux pays-bas arrivée
des premiers groupes de réfugiés en
provenance de macédoine 150 personnes
dont près d'un quart d'enfants sont
arrivés eindhoven à bord d'un avion
militaire
les autorités néerlandaises se sont
engagés à accueillir quelques 2000
réfugiés
l'actualité de ce dimanche avec de la
politique française après la réunion des
cadres du rpr hier c'était au tour de
l'udf de tenir son conseil national
aujourd'hui françois bayrou bien décidé
à se lancer et ardemment dans la
campagne a égratigné au passage ses
anciens amis du parti gaulliste
tout en plaidant pour le renouveau de
l'opposition car le comme offrande
saillant
l'arrivée de françois bayrou longuement
applaudie par cycle le maintien de la
liste udf qui devait officiellement être
entérinée aujourd'hui me fait déjà plus
aucun doute encore étonnés de leur
propre masse les centristes ont donc
adressé une fin de non recevoir aux
appels à l'union du rpr pour défendre
leur projet longuement décliner ce matin
d'une europe qu'ils veulent d'abord
fédéral une campagne que françois bayrou
qui se réclame lui aussi du président de
la république entend mener au nom du
renouveau de l'opposition l'opposition
va quitter les habits couleur muraille
enfin on va de nouveau pouvoir donner au
projet leur place aux idées la
reconnaissance qui leur est dû et nous
nous allons enfin occuper le grand
espace réformateurs européens solidaire
dont on a besoin pour la politique
française
un grand parti du centre l'ambition de
françois bayrou est ancien il espère
désormais faire de ces élections
européennes
la première étape victorieuse de son
projet aux vaincus du bien fondé de sa
démarche l'udf s'émancipe et plutôt
qu'une division de la droite préfère y
voir le début de cette opposition
nouvelle que tous ont appelé de leurs
voeux ici aujourd'hui une opposition
plurielle
la grève du personnel au sol d'air
france à nice une nouvelle fois
reconduite manifestation aux abords de
l'aéroport cet après-midi un mouvement
qui entrera demain dans son douzième
jour olivier ferrand qui a dit richard
l'avion c'est sûr il attendra parce que
les passagers vont devoir rejoindre
l'aérogare à pied
les grévistes ont décidé de bloquer les
voies d'accès à l'aéroport du coup avant
de s'envoler faut marcher
l'initiative ne fait pas l'unanimité
sous le soleil ça passe de l'aéroport
les grévistes n'ont trouvé que ce biais
pour continuer à faire entendre leurs
revendications
les négociations d'hier ont tourné court
les propositions de la direction
régionale ont été jugées ridicules et
surtout l'idée de déléguer une partie de
l'activité au seul à une société de sous
traitance n'a pas été abandonné par la
direction les grévistes affirment qu'il
se bat d'abord pour air france et pour
les voyageurs on est en train de
travailler pour une bonne qualité de
service et une grandissime sécurité au
niveau du professionnalisme des métiers
du transport aérien à la compagnie on
n'a rien à cacher voire l'usagé alors
c'est sûr que l'usagé il est tracassé
pourquoi parce qu'il arrive en retard à
l'enregistrement
il a son avis en retard à l'heure
actuelle je crois que ça vaut quand même
la peine
la direction ne comprend pas les soucis
des grévistes affirment que le plan de
restructuration garantit les emplois et
va même entraîner des créations de
postes le recours à la sous traitance
une évolution inéluctable
il est vrai que les emplois non
qualifiés qui correspondent pas à notre
métier de base doivent aller à la
sous-traitance et c'est le propos et
nous voulons négocier les conditions
sociales et d'amélioration de notre
productivité à nice en particulier en
fin d'après-midi un gréviste aurait reçu
un coup par un cadre d'air france il a
été hospitalisé
les négociations vont donc avoir du mal
à reprendre sereinement demain en tout
cas 80% du trafic aérien sera assuré en
seine-saint-denis les matchs de football
sur les stats suspendu pendant trois
semaines pour cause de violences ont
repris aujourd'hui avec l'encadrement
d'une cellule sécurité un dispositif que
nous détaille patrick fandio et abdel
juillet
pour ces agents de police c'est un peu
le jour j pour la première fois la
cellule sécurité sport se met en place
désormais tous les appels signalant des
incidents sur les stades de seine saint
denis aboutiront directement ici pour
eux c'est aussi une première ces
policiers inaugure cette après midi pour
la reprise des matchs dans les
parlements une sorte de patrouille des
stades avec une mission bien délimitées
sont restées aux abords un petit peu
plus lointain et stone verrons d'autres
policiers qui sont habituellement des
policiers de proximité qui vont faire la
tâche aux abords du caire et l'un des
terrains placé sous haute surveillance
se trouvent aux abords de la cité 3000 à
aulnay sous bois une présence policière
discrète pour un derby annoncé explosifs
deux clubs rivaux de la même cité qui
nourrissent un vieux contentieux trois
semaines d'interruption n'ont pas à
changer les habitudes
les supporters se livrent à leur jeu
favori provoquer l'adversaire exciter
les arbitres
pour eux ce n'est qu'un jeu et la police
n'y changera rien c'est pas d incidence
et surtout de la violence verbale
la police est bien calé la france à
chaud les quais swallows quand tu seras
de constamment c'est inutile suis pas au
contraire peut-être que ça va
même son de cloche chez les éducateurs
qui assistent aux matchs la police c'est
bien mais ce qu'il faut d'urgence et
renforcer l'encadrement sportif et
éducatif de ces clubs
le problème qu'on rencontre dans les
clubs de quartier c'est le manque de
dirigeants
on n'a pas assez de bénévoles et
j'emploie le bénévolat c'est fini ça
existe plus le bénévolat de nos jours de
que faut trouver un moyen d'attirer
ce soit les grands frères de les attirer
sur les stades est avec toi on voit
toute la violence qui a personne en vous
tous sont persuadés ici qu'on ne règlera
rien dans l'urgence et que ce travail de
reconquête des stades prendra beaucoup
de temps
journée nationale de la déportation la
france rend hommage aujourd'hui aux
dizaines de milliers de victimes des
camps de concentration du troisième
reich cérémonie cet après midi au
mémorial du martyr juif inconnu en
présence du secrétaire national des
anciens combattants jean terme à ce raid
deux autres cérémonies devrait se tenir
l'une à lise de la cité l'autre à l'arc
de triomphe
entre 1942 et 44 75 mille juifs dont
plus de dix mille enfants et adolescents
ont été déportés de france
la plupart depuis drancy aux états unis
cérémonie du souvenir à la mémoire des
victimes massacrées dans le lycée de
lyttelton le vice président al gore
participent à cet hommage
alors qu'hier les obsèques d'une jeune
fille de 17 ans sont déroulées en
présence de quelques 3000 personnes
les enquêteurs ont par ailleurs
découvert le journal intime d'un des
tueurs qui relate la préparation depuis
un an de ce projet meurtrier dominique
derda sur son cercueil quelques mots
d'adieu et sur tous les visages des
larmes qui semble jamais ne vouloir
s'arrêter de couler
les funérailles de rachel scott sont les
premières d'une longue série celle des
15 victimes de la tuerie du lycée de
columbine rachel avait 17 ans elle
rêvait de faire du théâtre ou du cinéma
c'était une fille formidable dit sa
meilleure amie la voix brisée par
l'émotion elle était si drôle et si
plein de vie
elle nous faisait tous rire de sa
voiture qu'elle avait garé ce matin là
devant le lycée avant d'aller en cours
ils ont fait un mémorial tu seras mieux
au paradis peut-on lire sur cette
affiche
ça aurait pu être l'un de nos enfants
dit cette mère de famille pendant ce
temps l'enquêté se poursuit en
perquisitionnant la maison de l'un des
jeunes tueurs la police a mis la main
sur son journal intime
on y découvre qu'il préparait depuis un
an l'attak de leur école pour ce 20
avril jour anniversaire de la naissance
dicle
nous l'a dit chérif est imprégnée de
référence au nazisme pendant tout ce
temps ils ont fabriqué leur bombe
ils se sont procuré des armes ce que
l'on recherche actuellement c'est où ils
ont trouvé que cet arsenal et l'on parle
toujours d'éventuels complices qui les
auraient aidé à transporter à
l'intérieur des bâtiments la trentaine
d'explosifs
il pourrait y avoir un troisième suspect
un quatrième un cinquième il pourrait
même être plus nombreux encore nous
n'excluons aucune piste
la fusillade a relancé le débat sur le
contrôle de la vente des armes aux états
unis pour la première fois un sondage
indiquent qu'un américain sur deux est
favorable à une loi interdisant la
détention d'armes à feu
mais le tout puissant lobby des armes
n'entend pas baisser la garde pour
autant malgré l'émotion suscitée par la
tuerie la nra maintien pour le 30 avril
son congrès annuel à denver avec comme
têtes d'affiché l'acteur charlton est à
londres après l'attentât raciste qui
s'est produit hier en fin de journée
cinq personnes ont été blessées
c'est un groupe d'extrême droite baptisé
combat 18 qui a revendiqué cette
explosion à la voiture piégée tout juste
une semaine après un premier attentat
identiques qui s'était déroulée à une
heure d'affluence ces images ont été
filmées hier par avec deux amateurs
sport en championnat de france de
football le paris saint germain battu le
havre 3 0 au parc des princes très belle
performance pour les parisiens qui grâce
à cette victoire grimpent à la neuvième
place du classement du championnat le
psg compte maintenant sept points
d'avancé sur lorient
le premier relégable en deuxième
division
et puis du tennis avec la finale de
monte carlo le brésilien gustavo kuerten
a remporté la compétition après la bande
au de marcello rios en raison d'une
blessure à la cuisse curtain menait
alors 6 4 2 1 au moment où son
adversaire après 54 minutes de jeu a
déclaré forfait
c'est la fin de la saison de ski dans
les alpes à un bilan plus que positif
notamment dans les alpes du nord où les
derniers vacanciers profitent du soleil
et d'un bel enneigement à méribel qui
ferme le 2 mai car l'une marie et
philippe évêques les alpes du nord 1 25
avril à quelques jours de la fermeture
cela entament leur dernière descente de
la saison
accrochés à leurs bâtons incapable
d'envisager la fin des vacances de neige
très bon oui c'est un combat bien si
2 mètres 70 de neige en haut des pistes
de quoi ravir les amateurs de ski
printanier c'est un autre type de
vacances et la dernière semaine
c'est plus privé une fin de règne
heureuse donc les étrangers sont venus
nombreux cet hiver les remontées
mécaniques enregistre une hausse de 5%
du chiffre d'affaires
mais ce week-end c'est une clientèle
régionale qui profitent des conditions
exceptionnelles s'il fait beau les gens
peuvent venez en 1h 2h et diane ce qui
est pour les clients qui viennent de
plus loin c'est un peu plus difficile
c'est à dire qu'actuellement on a une
partie de notre clientèle la clientèle
étrangère qui est au des marmottes
regarder et de mémoire de marmottes
on n'avait jamais rien vu de pareil j'ai
vraiment parfois à la fin je sais pas
pour les motive on regarde ces dix de
mes choix et fait 10 degrés ce soir mais
les belles va fermer une partie de son
domaine skiable oublier le mauvais temps
du mois de février
les professionnels se sont réconciliés
avec la météo en alsace se tient le
festival du nouveau cirque va que hier
en ouverture le cirque baroque qui nous
entraîne dans l'univers de frankenstein
à obernai reportage de christine bost
patrick chercheurs
univers étrange et inquiétant pour un
livre fascinant
le mythe de frankenstein revisité sous
un chapiteau
exit les vieilles recettes le cirque
baroque des jouets se joue des arts du
cirque pour décliner l'univers de mary
shelley le principal vecteur c'est quand
même c'est le cirque est versée la
prouesse visible pour la bonne exécution
d'un geste est très importante elle est
importante pour la sécurité elle est
importante pour la lisibilité pour les
émotions qu'elle procure
et nous on était loin d superposés
d'autres émotions qui ont trait aux
sujets effectivement traités et parle ou
théâtralisation
les prouesses techniques qui ne sont pas
gratuits elles prennent tout leur sens
dans un spectacle total qui emprunte
aussi bien à la danse théâtre
les clowns jongleurs et acrobates sont
toujours là merloni aujourd'hui le
cirque n'est pas moribond il a même un
festival qui prendra quinze spectacles
différents
on s'est rendu compte que il y avait
tous ces courants émergents de cirque de
nouvelles formes d'expression de cirque
en france et on avait très envie de
faire partager ce plaisir ce plaisir du
nouveau cirque avec le public
chaque compagnie développe un univers
une expression qui lui est propre
toutes ont en commun un sens inné de la
poésie et de l'émotion
tous
cinéma avec la sortie mercredi prochain
sur les écrans du plus beau pays du
monde
réalisé par marcel bluwal la flume qui
racontent sous l'occupation
l'histoire vraie d'un jeune comédien qui
incarnait le rôle de mermoz dans un film
propagande avant d'être lui-même
déportés superbe distribution avec
claude brasseur que j'ai le plaisir de
recevoir dans un instant mais aussi
thierry lhermitte de marianne denicourt
à travers le tournage de ce film
la france de vichy stéphane haumant
février 42 on tourne sous veulent des
allemands l'avis de mermoz
un beau film de propagande sur les
exploits de l'aviateur
cette scène a vraiment une bulle le plus
beau pays du monde est une histoire
vraie ascension issu d'un jeune acteur
dans la france occupée
évocation d'un certain âge d'or
c'est d'abord un décidément les plus les
plus riches décident m'a foncé les plus
richement les enfants du paradis des
vagues
la grande époque degré millions prévert
de carné prévert et parce que les
beaucoup de cinéastes voulait faire
abstraction un black out de passer aux
gens ce qui se passait ce qui se passait
hors des studios tout simplement la
guerre et la déportation
l'histoire avec un grand h qui s'invite
dans la fiction le jour où lambert
l'acteur qui jouait mermoz fut arrêté
par la gestapo une semaine avant la fin
du tournage et déclarer quoi les
allemands au coin c'est votre crâne mais
vous rigolez
c'est une question de vie ou mort on est
en plein tournage les bras en plein
tournage
les temples mrd votre ami acteur
malherbe s'être enfoncé un peu plus que
ni le plus beau pays du monde c'est la
france n'est pas ironique et elle est
erronée quand même temps parce que c'est
la france de 1940 de cartes droit et il
ya plein de gens pour qui c'était le
plus beau pays du monde
ce n'est pas politique du tout tout le
monde ferme les yeux tout le monde
faisait comme si de rien n'était et on
continue à faire le cinéma est à faire
et à faire du divertissement pour
continuer le divertissement coûte que
coûte et surtout finir son film la
production engagera un autre mermoz qui
jouera les dernières scènes de dos la
trajectoire de ce mermoz de propagande
en dit long sur la cruauté du cinéma il
destin le droit c'est un bon soir vous
jouez donc le directeur de production de
ce film qui rend hommage à à mermoz un
acteur qui sera déporté une histoire
vraie nous y reviendrons mais je crois
savoir que l'histoire de ce film vous la
connaissiez depuis longtemps votre
famille vous l'avez raconter mais c'est
vrai ma mère moi la mode et le joyeux
qui était une grosse vedette a cédé
des films de d'otan laruns a épousé en
secondes noces un des plus grands chefs
opérateurs français philippe agostini
qui fut le chef opérateur de des grilles
millions de carnets à cette époque là
était assistant opérateur du film de
mermoz et un soir ont dit non à la
maison des médias leur tournée mermoz ou
alors elle m'a dit mais attends mais
est-ce que c'est pas ce film nous
l'acteur principal à a disparu pour des
histoires d'aider des choses très
bizarres il s'est fait arrêter enfin
effectivement et c'est comme ça que j'ai
entendu parler de de cette histoire est
en effet cet acteur a disparu et au
passage lors de la première du film donc
en 43 ou au gala de la croix rouge
personne ne va remarquer que l'acteur
n'est pas dans la salle
non parce que il avait été arrêté pour
des raisons très particulière en fait
c'était avait été arrêté dans une rafle
de l'homosexuel parce qu'il faut dire
qu'à l'époque il y avait non seulement
comme ça une répression contre les juifs
contre les résistants contre les
communistes au 21 mai enfin le fait à
l'époque être homosexuel était déjà
considéré comme une criminalité et pour
pour ce film qui avait été commandité
par vichy alors que ce film de
propagande du rhin et en français comme
au ski quand même faisait partie des
croix de feu et qui était d'extrême
droite fut déjà interprété comme ça face
à amer mousse très revisitée par la
censure fils c'est à dire que ces gens
si peut-être l'histoire de ce film
propagande prend une dimension
particulière bien sûr et le jour de la
première à l'opéra il y avait des ordres
qui émanait de vichy dix ans il ne faut
absolument pas que l'on sache pourquoi
que ce verrou ce que l'acteur qui
interprète le héros a été arrêté et
déporté
alors est ce que pour marcel bluwal mais
peut-être comme pour vous même il ya un
devoir de mémoire à l'égard de cet
acteur et peut-être même un devoir de
réparation parce que le monde du
spectacle et du théâtral suivant fermez
les yeux vous collaborez même
franchement eu leur mac on connaît les
derniers promet ya beaucoup de beaucoup
d'acteurs beaucoup de genres du cinéma
qui sont restés dans le
dans le pays qui ont continué de faire
leur métier alors mais ils sont ils
coupables ou pas c'est un éternel
problème et c'est vrai c'est vrai ce que
disait tout à l'heure marseille pour y
arriver il y avait comme ça une volonté
de ne pas voir ce qui ce qui se passait
et d'aller au bout c'est d'ailleurs en
cela que le personnage que je joue et on
est vu un peu en vue
mais ça c'est des gars de jouer des
personnages ambigus à partir du moment
où le fond du film lui-même correspond à
mes idées ça m'est égal d'interpréter un
personnage qui ne correspond pas amélie
c'était pas grave mais pour lui c'est il
veut pas il veut pas savoir ce qui se
passe il a pour mission d'emmener son
équipe à la virage se tournent
aujourd'hui c'est la journée nationale
de la déportation et lambert a été donc
déporté il est mort en déportation
évidemment le film trouve là un écho
particulier avec des scènes très
violentes comme ces dernières phrases
qu'il dira derrière les barbelés de
drancy mais ça c'est une c'est une
séquence qu'il vaut mieux laisser
découvrir aux spectateurs et une
séquence mais qui est absolument
authentiques un peu de tout à fait vrai
qu'est ce qu'on doit retenir du film si
on devait en retenir quelque chose donc
c'est moi qui ai déjà le cinéma souvent
abordé ce thème du divertissement du
théâtre sous l'occupation
celui ci peut être une novateur à sa
façon il est novateur en ce sens jeudi
d'une part on découvre qu'il y avait
cette répression comme ça pas simplement
sur tout ce qu'on dit et puis également
cette volonté comme ça de beaucoup de
gens et c'est plus un film non seulement
c'est pas tellement un film qui dénonce
et surtout un film qu'ils posent des
questions est ce que ces gens et
beaucoup d'acteurs qui sont restés pour
faire du théâtre est ce que est ce qu'il
ce qu'ils ont raison est ce qu'ils
avaient raison et qu'est ce qu'on ferait
nous cessons jose a le le problème alors
peut-être plus année docti est plus
anecdotique mais plus léger est
intéressant aussi c'est le regard des
comédiens de l'époque sur le cinéma
oui peut-être même votre propre père
avait t-il ce regard amusé sur le cinéma
oui mais je pense que d'abord il ya une
chose très importante
indépendamment de la de l'époque et de
la répression et de l'occupation
je remarquai en entendant comme ça mon
père converser avec les jouvet les blier
autres il ne méprisait pas du tout le
cinéma muet il prenait pas ça très au
sérieux lui leur métier c'était le
théâtre avant tout alors comme il disait
à l'époque et qui faisait du cinéma pour
payer les impôts sans vouloir exagérer
il avait un peu le même rapport que nous
on a aujourd'hui avec la pub si lointain
est-ce que je vais les échappements
entendu parler très sérieusement de film
je me souviens de deux copains - comme
webber est aussi claire on va bouffer
avec ton père il va nous parler des
enfants du paradis
nous allons parler des autres départs du
web c'est sympa mais dès qu'il commence
à parler de théâtre las de c'était un
autre ton merci et que brasseur d'avoir
répondu à nos questions après merci
c'est la fin de ce journal je vous en
rappelle les principaux titres jacques
chirac qui avait initié une rencontre
avec les pays voisins de l'eiu de ce
clavier les membres de l'otan a tenu une
conférence de presse dans un message à
former le français il revient sur la
situation au kosovo réaffirmant l'unité
de le temps contre slobodan milosevic
fermeté de ton du président de la
république qui met en garde la serbie
contre un coup de force au monténégro et
puis donc la fin du sommet de l'otan à
washington la réunion des sept pays
voisins de la grèce la vie avec je
lisais les membres de l'alliance pour un
pacte de stabilité dans les balkans dans
un instant la météo laurent romejko
20h50 les soeurs soleil avec clémentine
célarié marie-anne chazel fehrer 30 le
dernier journal laurence seule alsace de
master 50 dans les 4 vérités
marie pierre farkas recevra hervé de
charette amateurs vous retrouverez
claude sérillon je vous remercie de
votre attention excellente fin de soirée
sur france 2
tous